[Music]
joseph is with us joseph is in salt lake
city hi joseph how are you
i'm doing pretty good how about yourself
better than i deserve how can we help
um so i'm 21 years old i just came back
from the summer of selling pest control
and i and i made a hundred and seventeen
thousand dollars
i i don't have i pay for myself to go to
college i don't have any car debts i
don't have any mortgage or anything like
that
and i was just wondering what your best
advice would be going forward i i read
dave ramsey going growing up and my
parents have been helping me through it
and i've got an emergency fund set aside
for 10 grand and i mean i could start
going into investments like roth iras or
i don't know trying to
like save for a house you know save for
a house so i can just buy it after
college what would you recommend
i i do at this point in my life
so
is this your long-term plan do you want
to stay in pest control do you enjoy it
um i mean i'll probably do it for the
next five years but you said you're
going to college
yeah i'm going to college right now i
currently go every uh fall and winter
it's 10k total for that
and i pay for myself to go to college
during the summer time i go sell pest
control so i'll probably do that for
five years until i graduate and then
i'll just get some kind of job i'll
probably go into a business management
degree or something like that yeah what
are you studying is college
i'm studying business management
currently okay
did you want to be an entrepreneur and
run your own business
yeah that was always the dream to do but
um
you know just
life beats you down sometimes so going
to college right now because i know
that's a very good thing to do at my age
and i can always have that as a fallback
but yeah definitely i will go ahead and
finish that degree as fast as possible
and you've got how much did you have
saved out of this hundred grand
so i have a 117 grand is what i came
back with okay um after taxes it'll
probably be about 88 grand i'm gonna pay
my tithing on that got my emergency fund
and the two semesters and and i bought a
car in cash because you know i needed a
car
good yeah
young man car stuff what did you buy how
much did you spend on the car
it was nine grand i got a 2007 ford
mustang per pt so i love it very good
all right so yeah
all i'm going to do is what cash is left
after all the different things you
listed out there
i'm just going to stack cash it's
college insurance plan
it's ensuring that you go through
colleges after that it's ensuring that
you go through college you don't need to
start roth iras you don't need to start
a house fund you need to go through
college
debt-free
and you've you've got this lined up so
you pay your taxes you pay your tithe
you
pay for the car
you set your emergency fund aside and
then you stack cash and if you graduate
from college with 50 or 60 grand
in that account then we can talk about
starting to invest then or buying a home
then just take it easy man you're you're
just a ghost you're so far ahead of the
game you're a go-getter man you're a
hustler that's good that's on grind man
you're doing great big piles of cash get
through school then start your investing
in house buying that's what i would do